I think if you had to point out one
particular area it's really technology
it's technology is really accelerating
at such a pace with an industry within
manufacturing but for the first time
we've really been able to commercially
blend the the old traditional skills of
shoemaking were that of new technology
that you might find in automotive or
aeronautical so the robot assisted
technology that you're deploying here
that will presumably mean less people
are actually used in the workforce you
do you do have less in comparison say to
the old traditional ways of shoemaking
which you would have been familiar with
say in the 1960s or 1970s but what this
does require is extremely skilled people
so whilst you still have to have a high
skill base for shoemaking elements of it
you're still going to have people coming
in with digital skills with coding
skills robotics so it's really injecting
a whole new skill base into what was
traditionally a very labor intensive
industry and is this the first
manufacturing base around the world for
you where you're deploying this this
robot assisted technology yeah following
the pilot that we've been running for a
fair time just under a year this will be
the first operational commercial unit
that will set up and of course we chose
to put it bring it back to the UK in
Somerset in Street and in the HQ where
it all started nearly 200 years ago and
the will you be pressing the made in
Britain aspect to that very aggressively
to consumers well I think when you look
at the global consumer nowadays they're
all linked digitally everybody has seen
the same thing at the same time and
there is a strong demand for English
made products not just in the UK but
also in parts of Europe and in Asia and
the United States I think when you link
that well with the heritage brand like
Clark's and you create something really
quite special I think the demand will be
very very strong now you're obviously
the UK's fourth the world's fourth
largest shoe maker how do you see brexit
is it a risk or an opportunity for you
it's a good question I think an
opportunity really at the end of the day
we're still a couple of years out from
knowing quite what will happen but
Clarke's is incredibly diversified
global business and we're just weird
we're in the same boat as everybody else
we're going to work our way through it
but we are going to ensure that we're
flexible and agile as we work through
we've got time to do that and not that
bringing manufacturing back to the UK
was by any means a reaction to bricks it
on our behalf we started this long
before that but what it does do is
ensures that we start to get that
agility and flexibility built into our
operations so necessarily leaving the
single market wouldn't be a big problem
for you not necessarily a big problem
but like I said I mean nobody knows
nobody knows the outcome yet so we still
got to work waita through but we are
diversified enough to I think find the
opportunity within it I'm what about
consumer confidence here in the UK right
now in high street sales haven't been
great this year you see much of a
drop-off in in sales here in the UK
we're finding it reasonably stable and
our retail estate things are reasonably
stable
you've got to execute everything is
extremely well I think it's a type of
environment where if you do make any
errors you do make any mistakes it's a
can be a punishing environment but
clark's have been reacting to the
situation extremely well we're holding
our full price sales and I think you
know all in all we're quite happy with
the environment